herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen diese corona
pandemie hält uns seit über einem jahr
in ihrem bann
täglich und in allen lebensbereichen
kurz vor ostern sind wir mitten in der
dritten welle mit ansteckenden virus
mutationen
zunehmend sind auch kinder betroffen
wir sehen uns alle wir sehen uns
wirklich alle nach mehr normalität und
spüren gleichzeitig dass die pandemie
noch nicht zu ende ist und es noch
dauert bis alle geimpft sind und ja das
verlangt verdammt viel von allem ab und
deshalb will ich hier heute zuerst mal
danke sagen an all jene die uns im kampf
gegen das virus täglich unterstützen
denn nach wie vor tun viele menschen
sehr viel damit das virus nicht noch
stärker wird im privaten in den schulen
und kitas in den verwaltungen bei der
arbeit und natürlich ganz besonders in
krankenhäusern arztpraxen impfzentren
und pflegeheime sie alle
sie alle haben unseren respekt und
unseren dank verdient
ich will in meiner rede jedoch den fokus
auf familien und kinder leben
denn darüber wird mir zu wenig
gesprochen
immer wieder sagen wir den satz es sind
familien die unser land durch diese
pandemie tragen das stimmt aber gerade
kinder leiden doch ganz besonders denn
kinder brauchen andere kinder um sich
gut zu entwickeln
nach wie vor ist da keine normalität in
sicht freunde treffen sport und freizeit
all das leidet und die kinder leiden
darum weil ich gleis wann diese
normalität
zurückkehrt brauchen wir neben dem
impfen andere möglichkeiten für
möglichst viel normalität
es ist wichtig und richtig dass wir
einen politischen konsens haben schulen
und kitas zuerst und womöglich sie auch
offen halten aber dieses ziel das
braucht doch mehr aufmerksamkeit denn
auch schulen und kitas werden zunehmend
zu hotspots
wenn wir dort nichts ändern und deshalb
bin ich davon überzeugt dass wir eine
ehrgeizigere test strategie brauchen
gerade für unsere kleinen wie es unsere
bundesfamilienministerin franziska
giffey immer wieder auch auf die
tagesordnung setzt es ist nicht nur für
mich sondern für viele menschen im land
nicht nachvollziehbar wieso kinder in
kitas nicht verbindlich getestet werden
im gegensatz zu den grundschulen wo das
stattfindet oder stattfinden soll müssen
wir da nicht mehr ehrgeiz wagen müssen
wir da nicht eigentlich an dem ziel
arbeiten gerade unsere kinder täglich zu
testen damit kitas offen bleiben können
nicht zur hot spots werden und familien
entlastet werden
ich weiß dass es da große
herausforderungen gibt aber müssen wir
nicht sagen wo wir hin wollen und ich
will zu täglichen tests für kinder und
erwachsene in schulen und kitas damit
wir unser versprechen schulen und kitas
zuerst mit leben füllen und seit vielen
monaten stecken familien im dauer spagat
aus rolling home office und
kinderbetreuung in einer riesen
kraftanstrengung ist es uns anfang des
jahres gelungen
dafür den familien zeit zu geben wir
haben die kinder krankentage verdoppelt
und die voraussetzungen dafür verbessert
doch jetzt im lock down sind die kinder
krankentage teilweise aufgebraucht die
familien wird nötigen sie aber nicht nur
während der pandemie sondern darüber
hinaus den kinder werden nicht nur bis
märz krank sondern bis dezember
lange rede kurzer sinn ich finde wir
brauchen mehr kinder krankentage um die
familien erneut zu entlasten in diesem
besonderen jahr für mich ist klar wir
stärken kinder und familien indem wir
sie unterstützen und mehr politische
aufmerksamkeit für verbindliche tests
geben
das stärkt natürlich die familien selbst
es ist unser aller anliegen aber es
stärkt vor allen dingen auch das soziale
und den sozialen zusammenhalt wie rolf
mützenich verein hier auch eingefordert
hat für die spd bundestagsfraktion
denn corona tests sind eine
brückentechnologie bis alle geimpft sind
und natürlich sollte das was in kita und
schule gilt selbstverständlich auch am
arbeitsplatz gelten mehr und regelmäßige
tests mehr notwendig auch verbindlich
stadt freiwillig weil nur dann machen
nutzen wir diese brückentechnologie für
alle
auch wenn viele menschen in dieser woche
vor ostern müde sind 130 ostern ist das
fest der auferstehung ostern bedeutet
ein neues leben ein neues leben
das können wir auch wenn wir alle
gemeinsam in eine richtung gehen die
pandemie besiegen wir gemeinsam und
solidarisch helfen sie alle mit katja
maaß war das stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd-fraktion und sie
verbindet die osterbotschaft auch mit
der aussicht auf bessere zeiten in einer
nach pandemie zeit oder zumindest in
einer pandemie zeit in der mehr getestet
wurde grund vor allem mehr geld rein
theoretisch müsste es jetzt ums geld
gehen deren albrecht glaser ist auf dem
weg zum pult für die afg fraktion und in
der ist ja finanzpolitischer sprecher
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ein kernthema des
europäischen rates soll der binnenmarkt
der eu seien bei dessen ankündigung ist
ein papier des europäischen rats
hinterlegt dort ist von der vertiefung
des binnenmarktes für einen kräftigen
wieder aufschwung und ein
wettbewerbsfähiges nachhaltiges europa
die rede und auch davon dass die
führungsspitzen der eu dazu aufrufen ein
neues system der globalen wirtschafts
politischen steuerung zu errichten
diese und viele weitere seltsame
formulierungen ergeben ein bild von der
scheinwelt der euro kratie wir brauchen
mehr schulden für die erholung europas
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das ist auch die fantasie des
finanzministers resilienz durch
steuererhöhungen obwohl europa schon
über 100 prozent staatsschulden
großstadt hat und wir haben eine
steigende tendenz
lassen sie nicht also zum wichtigen
dingen in sachen mit den markt kommen
eine markante professorale stimme hat
sich soeben zum eigenen eigenmittel
beschluss wie folgt ich zitiere wir
stehen vor der größten weichenstellung
in der geschichte der europäischen
union seit einführung des euro es ist
gleichzeitig auch die teuerste
veränderung und auch der größte bruch
vertraglicher verpflichtungen
zitat ende schon in früheren jahren so
ein zitat hatte bergen keinen hehl
daraus gemacht wohin die europäische
entwicklung aus ihrer sicht gehen soll
die eu-kommission solle eine europäische
regierung werden das eu parlament
gestärkt und der mächtigen eu rat der 27
regierungen die rolle einer länderkammer
einnehmen so merkel 2012 schreibt das
redaktions werk das uns wecken rät
netzwerk tor stellt merkens projekt ist
also die auflösung der deutschen
staatlichkeit der staatlichkeit auch
andere demokratie in europa und damit
natürlich auch eine auflösung der
parlamentarischen demokratie als
staatsform in europa ein großer schritt
in diese richtung soll mit der
ratifizierung des 1 0 beschlusses des
rates durch dieses parlament vollzogen
werden
jeder diesem harmlosen etikett verbirgt
sich eine epochale entscheidung erstmals
in ihrer geschichte wird die eu über
anleihen erhebliche mittel am
kapitalmarkt aufnehmen und den
mitgliedstaaten als verlorene zuschüsse
zur verfügung stellen schreibt der
bundesrechnungshof in diesen tagen dort
zutat der wiederaufbau vor
dieses abenteuer pathetisch genannt wird
ist ein schulden finanzierter transfer
zwischen den mitgliedstaaten schreibt
der bundesrechnungshof ebenfalls wort
zitat ich die verschuldung der eu für
das absurde projekt wird über eine
inflations sicherung in wahrheit 800
milliarden betragen
zu deren finanzierung will die eu ein
zugriffsrecht auf zusätzlich 0,6 prozent
des bruttonationaleinkommens eines jeden
mitgliedsstaates das sind meine damen
und herren 4 billionen zusätzlich
gegenüber dem geltenden rechts zustand
diese erhöhte zugriff der eu soll nur
vorübergehend bis 20 58 möglich sein
vorübergehend im verständnis der eu
bedeutet also einen zeitraum von knapp
40 jahren
vielleicht hatten wir alle einen anderen
vorübergehenden dürfen bisher zu recht
kalkuliert die eu das risiko ein dass
mitgliedstaaten den mittelabruf ganz
oder teilweise nicht rechtzeitig
nachkommen oder mitteilen dass sie dem
aufruf nicht nachkommen können so der
wortlaut des artikel 9 absatz 5 des
eigenen beschluss dass die teilen mit
wir wollen nicht zahlen
und in diesem fall kann die kommission
andere mitgliedstaaten ersatzweise in
anspruch nehmen das unterschreiten wir
übermorgen wenn wir morgen diesen pakt
beschließen
dabei geht es wie ein seriöser professor
ausgerechnet hat für deutschland um ein
maximales haftungsrisiko von 800
milliarden
damit sind wir bei des pudels kern wo
ist in den verträgen die begrenzten
einzelermächtigung für die eu zu finden
geld für resilienz digitalisierung und
ökologische transformation in europa zu
verteilen
eine solche bräuchte es nach artikel 5
absatz 2 des eu voraus ergibt sich die
ermächtigung der eu mehr als 800
milliarden kredite aufzunehmen diese als
eigenmittel um zu etikettieren und die
mitgliedstaaten zu verpflichten die
generationen der nächsten 40 jahre in
schuldknechtschaft zu nehmen
wo nehmen die eu-organe die
bundesregierung dieser bundestag das
recht her für dieses land haftungen für
schulden anderer mitgliedstaaten zu
übernehmen obwohl nach artikel 125
absatz 1 satz 1 des asv dies wörtlich
und sinngemäß verboten ist
die kanzlerin hat 20 12 jörg antl für
ganz europa hörbar erklärt eine
gesamtschuldnerische haftung wird es
nicht geben solange ich lebe ich
wiederhole das vom vergangenen tag eine
ähnliche botschaft hatte die ihm bei der
einführung des eu an jeden laternen
mast gehängt muss deutschland für die
schulden anderer länder aufkommen hin da
zu lesen
ein ganz klares nein in artikel 9 absatz
5 des eigentlichen beschlusses lesen der
schwarz auf weiß genau das gegenteil von
dieser parole
ökonomisch ist diese helikopter
geldverteilung nicht nur sinnlos sondern
kontraproduktiv ich komme zum schluss
herr präsident die hoch verschuldeten
länder mit einer wohlhabenden
bevölkerung und niederen steuern werden
von weniger verschuldeten mit höherer
steuer las alimentiert die soliden soll
im gemeinsamen haus den kühlschrank
füllen damit die unsortierten ihn lehren
können so funktioniert jedoch meine
damen und herren keine wohngemeinschaft
und eine starken gemeinschaft schon gar
nicht ich wünsche ihnen allen ein gutes
gewissen bei der illegalen schulden und
taten die sie morgen feiern wollen
herzlich
albrecht glaser war das der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion löste die eine oder andere
etwas heftigere reaktionen aussehen den
rhein hat hier seine sicht auf die
europäische union dargestellt und
insbesondere auch seine sicht auf die
europäische finanzpolitik und wir gucken
wie es weitergeht in der aussprache zur
regierungserklärung die ja zum
europäischen rat war aber auch zu corona
politik jetzt alexander dobrindt
vorsitzende der csu-landesgruppe
liegenden und kollegen mangelnde
akzeptanz kann auch zu unkontrollierten
infektionsgeschehen führen ja genau
deswegen ist es so entscheidend dass wir
die balance halten zwischen der distanz
auf der einen seite und der akzeptanz
auf der anderen seite und deswegen war
es auch richtig dass diese entscheidung
zur oster ruhe zurück genommen wurde und
wir haben respekt vor genau diese
entscheidung weil es deutlich geworden
ist dass sie schwer umsetzbar ist weil
sie die balance zwischen vorsicht und
perspektive nicht ausreichend gehalten
hat aber das liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen entbindet uns in keinster weise
davon entscheidungen zu treffen die das
infektionsgeschehen nach unten drücken
werden wir haben immer noch eine
dynamisches infektionsgeschehen 20.000
neuinfektionen das ist alles andere als
eine pandemie die unter kontrolle ist
und deswegen sind maßnahmen notwendige
dieses infektionsgeschehen nach unten zu
drücken meine damen und herren
fast 20.000 neue infektionen das ist
eindeutig zu viel
ein dynamisch steigendes incidents
wachstum das ist eindeutig zu schnell
eine virusvariante die besonders in
jüngeren
als gruppen aktiv ist das ist eindeutig
die falsche entwicklung und wir können
das in unserer nachbarschaft in
österreich sehr genau beobachten wie
diese entwicklung mit der virusvariante
voranschreitet in niederösterreich in
salzburg im burgenland sind es gerade
die jungen menschen die schülerinnen und
schüler die fünf bis 14 jährigen die
inzwischen eine inzidenz von 500
vorweisen
das infektionsgeschehen wird aus der
schule aus den jungen menschen heraus
getrieben deswegen gehen diese
bundesländer in österreich jetzt auch in
einen harten lockdown der unterricht
wird auch nach ostern digital
fortgesetzt wir haben jetzt die chance
in die osterferien in den schulen zu
gehen aber nach ostern wenn die schule
wieder beginnt dann brauchen wir auch
entsprechende konzepte in den schulen
die sind noch nicht ausreichend
es geht um die fehlenden luftfilter es
geht um die tests noch nicht stattfinden
wer die schulen nicht schließen will der
muss sie auch besser schützen das ist
der maßstab an dem es geht und ja
natürlich ist das aufgabe der länder das
ist richtig es wurde hier auch
entsprechend erwähnt aber das ergibt
trotzdem die möglichkeit in den bund
länder konferenzen in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch über
diese frage der schulen und der fortgang
der schulen der sicherung der schulen zu
reden wenn es nicht ausreichend
stattfindet und wir brauchen natürlich
auch wenn wir die perspektive geben
wollen über diese pandemie aus mit
öffnungen auch innovative konzepte dazu
gehört der digitale test passt dazu
gehört der digitale impfpass als ticket
zurück in die normalität und dazu gehört
auch das digitale zertifikat der eu ich
finde es richtig von bundeskanzlerin
dass über dieses zertifikat jetzt auch
im europäischen rat gesprochen wird
vereinbarungen getroffen wird und
natürlich kann man sich wenn man über
die frage der
diskutiert auch darüber auslassen dass
die geschwindigkeit mit der die eu
arbeitet nicht ausreichend genug ist
man kann sich natürlich darüber
unterhalten dass wir in den letzten
monaten festgestellt haben dass die eu
zu langsam agiert hat bei impfstoffen
und vielen anderen mehr
aber meine damen und herren ich bin auch
sehr klar sagen eine pandemie wie wir
sie erleben hat auch eine qualität die
europäischen länder auseinander zu
treiben
und ich bin froh und dankbar dass es
gelungen ist europa und die länder
zusammen zu halten in dieser frage und
dafür die richtigen entscheidungen zu
treffen meine damen und herren und sehr
geehrter herr glaser
sie haben sehr viel jetzt über die
europäischen verträge geredet
interpretationen dazu gegeben die ich
nicht für richtig erachte weil der
oberste grundsatz auch in der
europäischen union natürlich auch die
solidarität der mitgliedstaaten
untereinander ist und diese solidarität
leben wir hier
und sie haben einen widerspruch
aufgemacht zwischen souveränität und
solidarität nein ich sage ihnen es gibt
keinen widerspruch wissen souveränität
und solidarität es sind zwei seiten
einer medaille in europa und wir leben
beide und damit sind wir erfolgreich und
sehr geehrte damen und herren im
nachgang zu der bund länder konferenz
gibt es zu recht auf eine debatte
darüber ob wir die entscheidungsprozesse
auf den prüfstand stellen müssen
ja ich glaube die entscheidungsprozesse
müssen sich auch verändern ich bin auch
dankbar dass die ministerpräsidenten
gestern und heute zum teil genau das
auch formuliert haben dass man die
entscheidungsprozesse verändern muss
bund länder konferenzen damit wir uns
richtig verstehen sind ein notwendiges
instrument waren auch an besonnen
notwendiges instrument gerade am anfang
der pandemie um einen breiten konsens zu
schaffen einen breiten konsens zwischen
den ländern zu schaffen um einen breiten
konsens auch zwischen den regierenden
parteien zu schaffen aber wenn es jetzt
darum geht eine pandemie die deutlich
länger dauert als dir das alle erwartet
haben zu bekämpfen dann brauchen wir
auch eine direkte anbindungen der paar
direkte anbindung der parlamente an
diese entscheidung dann brauchen wir
auch eine direkte anbindung des
deutschen bundestags an diese
entscheidungen die bund länder konferenz
ist ein notwendiges mittel aber sie darf
auch kein not parlament werden meine
damen und herren der deutschen
bundestages das parlament deswegen meine
dringende bitte wir brauchen bei den
entscheidungen die auch in zukunft
anstehen und anstehen werden um diese
pandemie zu bekämpfen einen neuen stil
auch in der abstimmung mit den deutschen
bundestag dann kann daraus auch wieder
akzeptanz erschaffen werden die dazu
führt dass wir gemeinsam diese pandemie
erfolgreich bekämpft herzlichen dank
alexander dobrindt der vorsitzende der
csu-landesgruppe warnte dass die eu in
der pandemie auseinander driften könnte
äußert aber auch die zufriedenheit dass
es bislang nicht geschehen ist und hofft
dass das auch nicht geschehen wird und
im hinblick auf die bund länder runde
dieses gremium das in den vergangenen
tagen ganz besonders intensiv aus gutem
grund diskutiert worden ist da fordert
er eine direkte anbindung der
entscheidung dort an die parlamente und
natürlich auch an die enten bundestag
andrej hunko ist der nächste redner
europapolitischer sprecher der
linksfraktion
bei einer debatte zum europäischen rat
weitestgehend eine nationale krone
diskussion das ist eigentlich so nicht
angemessen wir brauchen hier endlich
eine angemessene einbindung dieses
parlament zur corona diskussion und
nicht ersatzweise bei der debatte zum
europäischen rat wo bundeskanzlerin ich
fürchte sie werden bei diesem gipfel den
gleichen fehler machen wie im oktober
2015 was das verhältnis zu erdogan
angeht
jetzt ist vorgesehen eine positiv agenda
mit der türkei auch 2015 war errang mit
dem rücken zur wand wie jetzt damals
sind sie nach istanbul gefahren haben
auch eine positiv agenda vorgelegt und
durch erdogan konnte sich gerade noch
mal über die wahlen am ersten november
retten
ich finde angesichts der zeichen der
letzten tage und wochen dem verbot der
verbots drohung der zweit größten
oppositionspartei der hdp denn weiterhin
der nichtumsetzung der urteile zu den
mythos und kavala dem nächtlichen
ausstieg aus der istanbul konvention den
waffen den drogen auch im türkisch
besetzten teil zyperns deutsche
leopard-panzer sind ich finde angesichts
dieser agenda darf es keine positiv
agenda gehen darf es kein upgrade geben
keine zusätzlichen finanziellen hilfen
statt dessen muss endlich das umgesetzt
werden was die meisten europäischen
länder meisten eu länder mittlerweile
auch wollen nämlich ein waffenexport
verbot an erdogan also keine
positiv agenda zur istanbul konvention
es ist vieles richtiges gesagt worden
ist das eine großartige konvention ist
es unerträglich dass ver nächtlichen
dekret hieraus getreten wird aber auch
die eu sollte endlich diese konvention
ratifizieren und deutschland sollte die
vorbehalte in artikel 59 da geht es um
den aufenthaltsstatus von von gewalt
bedrohten frauen deren aufenthaltsstatus
unsicher ist zurück nehmen keine positiv
agenda für die total frau merkel haben
jetzt den gipfel vielen dank andrej
hunko europapolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion mit anmerkungen zur türkei
unter anderem mit einer forderung des
stopps von waffenexporten an die türkei
nächste rednerin wird hier franziska
brantner sein
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
auch sie ist europapolitische sprecherin
und jetzt geht s tatsächlich hier in
dieser debatte auch noch mal um
europapolitische fragen also dem
eigentlichen kern der
regierungserklärung der kanzlerin vor
fast genau einem jahr haben sie frau
bundeskanzlerin hier vor dem bundestag
folgenden satz gesagt wir haben in
dieser krise auch die aufgabe zu zeigen
wer wir als europa sein wollen
ein jahr später fehlt es immer noch an
impfstoff an tests und viele
unverheiratete paare können sich wieder
oder immer noch nicht sehen sie sie
hatten als deutschen eu
ratspräsidentschaft sechs monate zeit um
impfstoff und test strategien zu
koordinieren um ihre
produktionskapazitäten zu stärken das
haben sie versäumt und die
bundesregierung hat beim impfstoff für
die produktion auf den markt gesetzt
sie hat geglaubt dass der markt schon
liefert wenn der preis hoch genug ist
schräge stimmen weil ich gravierender
fehler
dabei zeigen die usa wie es geht mit
einer impfstoff wirtschaft wir müssen
jeden einzelnen schritt in den
lieferketten koordinieren finanziell
stärken und wo nötig eben auch
regulieren
wer das immer noch mit planwirtschaft
wer unglück der hat den schuss nicht
gehört und deswegen müssen wir auch beim
thema impfstoff exporte ganz klar sein
der globale süden braucht dringend im
stoff hier müssen wir solidarisch sein
aber genauso klar muss sein wer selbst
impfstoff produziert bereits eine hohe
impfquote hat und sich trotzdem weigert
impfstoff zu teilen der muss auch mit
einem europäischen exportstopp rechnen
und ich erwarte dass sie sich frau
merkel wenn boris johnson jetzt der
europäischen union brot dass sie sich
vor die europäische kommission stellen
und klarstellen diese ungerechtigkeit
die akzeptiert die europäische union ist
und erlauben sie mir zur türkei frau
merkel sie haben gesagt der umgang mit
der hdp das parteiverbotsverfahren sei
bedauerlich das ist nicht bedauerlich
dass es einfach mit aller härte zu
kritisieren
das ist fatal und wenn wir mal
man spricht dass der austritt aus der
istanbul konvention ein falsches signal
sein
da kann ich nur sagen er hat nichts
verstanden frauenrechte sind der
gradmesser für demokratie und daran muss
man die tür keine messen
von daher ein zeichen der modernisierung
der zollunion ist zu diesem zeitpunkt
der absolut falsche schritt frau
bundeskanzlerin wir brauchen ein europa
das handelt nicht hadert sie haben
vorhin selber gesagt nehmen wir es in
die hand sie haben diese verantwortung
jetzt bei dem europäischen gipfel
übernehmen sie diese verantwortung und
machen sie was draus fordert franziska
brantner die europapolitische sprecherin
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen in
dieser aussprache zur
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
zum europäischen rat der heute per
videoschalte über die hätten nichts
rednerin in dieser debatte hier ist
katja nike art stellvertretende
vorsitzende der unions-fraktion und da
zuständig für den bereich europa und
außenpolitik
wie wäre die pandemie ohne die
europäische union verlaufen
ohne die große solidarität wie wir sie
in keinem anderen teil der welt gesehen
haben sicherlich schlechter für unsere
bevölkerung es hätte sicherlich mehr
schreckliche bilder gegeben wie aus
bergamo mehr todesfälle und mehr
wirtschaftlichen schaden unsere
europäische union kann in der krise
echte greifbare erfolge aufweisen und
vielleicht machen wir uns diese erfolge
auch ab und zu einfach mal bewusst mit
eu mitteln in höhe von einer milliarde
euro haben wir die erforschung von
impfstoffen und medikamenten europäisch
vorangetrieben nie gab es schneller
einen impfstoff auch das ist
ergebnis unseres zusammenhalts als
europäer
und es ist doch völlig illusorisch zu
glauben wir hätten uns mit 26 anderen
staaten zusammenraufen können um so viel
geld in die impfstoffforschung zu geben
dank dieser gemeinsamen investitionen
stehen eben nicht alle in fabriken in
china oder den usa
wir produzieren in europa aktuell an elf
standorten impfstoffe insgesamt könnten
über 26 standorte in europa produzieren
und genau da wollen wir hin da muss auch
europa besser werden mehr impfstoff
produktion in europa für europa und das
heißt überhaupt nicht dass wir jetzt
eine europa first strategie wollen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen denn einen
hochspezialisierten impfstoff wie von
beyond kann man eben nicht allein
herstellen
der in mainz entwickelte impfstoff hat
280 hochspezialisierte inhaltsstoffe aus
83 ländern
und das geht nur europäisch und das geht
übrigens auch nur international und
übrigens funktioniert auch die ganze
pandemie bekämpfung nur global
es hilft überhaupt niemanden wenn wir
nur die westliche welt immunisieren dann
marschieren die mutanten schneller auf
als wir impfen können die europäische
union handelt auch hier klug und
solidarisch wenn impfstoffe im rahmen
der kovacs initiative der whu in ärmere
länder exportiert werden frau göring
eckardt sieht das ja auch hier an dieser
stelle ganz genauso und lassen sie uns
bitte auch hier über die parteigrenzen
hinweg zusammen bleiben und vielleicht
sehen wir auch diese strategie der
europäischen union die für globale
verantwortung steht irgendwann einmal
als weitsichtige strategie zu würdigen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja die
europäische union hat nicht alles
richtig gemacht niemand hat in der
pfanne
nie alles richtig gemacht und es ist gut
wenn fehler eingestanden werden und
kurse korrigiert werden
aber wir müssen auch hier zwölf monate
nach ausbruch der pandemie die fakten
nicht aus den augen verlieren
und weil manche in dauerschleife
wiederholungen die bestellung seien
schlecht gelaufen oder die strategie sei
unklar
oder wie frau mohammed ali von der linke
vorhin von realsatire gesprochen hat
oder von katastrophe davon sind wir weit
entfernt
der impfstoff wurde gemeinsam optioniert
insgesamt 2,6 milliarden impfdosen sind
ausreichend bestimmt stellt für alle
europäerinnen europäer von hanau bis
porto von wilna bis palermo und diese
strategie wurde auch klar kommuniziert
bis zum sommer sollen 70 prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft sehen sein und wir
sehen es ja bei uns wie es vorangeht
aktuell impfen wir in deutschland alle
04 sekunden jeder zehnte hat bereits
eine impfung und ja natürlich muss das
schneller gehen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen lieber leider
gibt es auch tiefschläge und es ist
völlig inakzeptabel wenn wir erfahren
dass astrazeneca 29 millionen impfdosen
in der nähe von rom lagert wohl für den
export nach großbritannien und
gleichzeitig nur ein drittel der
zugesagten menge an die europäische
union geliefert und wir von der cdu csu
fraktion sind die letzten die
handelsbeschränkungen für gute grandiose
und lösung halten
wir haben ja auch einen
volkswirtschaftslehre aufgepasst aber
hier ist es richtig und er hat die
kommission unsere volle unterstützung
wenn sie den export dieser impfdosen
untersagt bis diese sache aufgeklärt ist
und im zweifel hilft dann eben auch nur
ein exportverbot auch das muss sie auch
europäische union lernen mehr gemeinsam
stärke zeigen
zur durchsetzung der eigenen interessen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
möchte auch noch auf den
wirtschaftlichen wiederaufbau zu
sprechen kommen weil ich ihn eben für
zentral halte auf sich allein gestellt
wären in europa längst mehrere staaten
bankrott gegangen weite teile der
deutschen wirtschaft während dabei in
mitleidenschaft gezogen und stattdessen
waren wir in der lage gemeinsam zu
agieren nicht nur über das eu
kurzarbeiter programm
das hat viel dazu beigetragen bei vielen
menschen über 25 millionen menschen in
europa neue hoffnung und sicherheit zu
geben ist ein erfolgsmodell made in
europe dann zu dem 750 milliarden corona
wiederaufbau voraus ein ganz klarer
verdienst der bundeskanzlerin jetzt
zeigt schon jetzt dass die finanzmärkte
damit stabilisiert werden konnten
herr glaser auf das ist vielleicht eine
einsicht für sie sind jetzt gar nicht
mehr da sich der euro ist nach wie vor
die zweitwichtigste währung der welt und
es war eine geschlossene antwort auf die
krise und wir von der cdu csu werden
größten wert darauf legen dass dieses
geld wie vorgesehen in die zukunft
investiert wird von digitalisierung des
klimaschutz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch dass
es klar europa muss lernen und braucht
reformen und was ralph brinkhaus vor ein
paar wochen für deutschland gefordert
hat eine kraftanstrengung um unser
staatswesen richtung zukunft
auszurichten das gilt eben auch für
europa das betrifft die stabilisierung
der euro-zone genauso wie den digitalen
binnenmarkt und auch eine globale
handelspolitik und genau deshalb ist es
gut dass die eu zukunfts kommunen können
selbstverständlich weiter sprechen tun
das aber auf kosten ihrer kollegen
ich komme zum ende und genau das muss
unser ziel sein dass die nächste krise
auf ein wehrhafter
das agileres europa treffen wird vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
katja la carte vize
fraktionsvorsitzender der unionsfraktion
sagt niemand hat alles richtig gemacht
auch nicht auf europäischer ebene
dennoch stehe die eu vergleichsweise gut
da in der pandemie wir schauen auf die
nächste und drittletzte rednerin in
dieser aussprache zur
regierungserklärung leser hat baradar
spd-fraktion in der fraktion mitglied in
einer arbeitsgruppe zu den folgen von
kogit 19 und sie ist kinderärztin mit
eigener praxis präsidentin sehr er die
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren
nach einem jahr bestimmt die korona
pandi mich weiterhin das leben der
menschen auf der ganzen welt die eu ist
leider davon nicht ausgenommen
stand heute sind über 900 36.000
menschen laut wie hoch der korona
pandemie in der europäischen union
gestorben
nach wie vor gehen wir auf einem sehr
langen und sehr steinigen weg bis wir
unser normales leben einigermaßen wieder
zurück haben könnte gleichfalls dürfen
wir den kopf nicht in den sand stecken
und müssen positiv ja wir müssen positiv
in die zukunft blicken denn es wird auch
ganz sicher eine zeit nach corona geben
wir müssen der eu endlich ein
erkennbares zeichen des aufbruchs setzen
der es unsere aufgabe aus dieser
pandemie die richtigen lehren für die
europäische gemeinschaft zu ziehen und
entsprechend konsequent zu handeln
die eu kommissionspräsidenten von der
leyen
sich gegenüber den impfstoff hersteller
noch erkennbar und nachhaltig
durchsetzen damit die zugesagte
lieferung auch wirklich ankommen ebenso
darf es in einer pandemie an einer so
entscheidenden stellen keine falsche
sparsamkeit geben um es ganz deutlich zu
sagen
dies ist völlig fehl am platz und hat
wie wir sie verheerende folgen
ich möchte an dieser stelle auch
konstatieren dass das eu programm mit
9,4 milliarden euro einfach zu kurz
gegriffen ist das wird uns noch
ordentlich vor die füße fallen wo
zeitnah zusätzliche impfstoffdosen
nachbestellt werden können muss dies
auch erfolgen transparent und offen
kommuniziert gerade bei der transparenz
gegenüber der öffentlichkeit aber auch
gegenüber den direkt gewählten
europaparlament hat es von seiten der
kommissionschef in den vergangenen
monaten an etlichen stellen erheblich
gemangelt
dies hat so ein klima des misstrauens
geführt den kolleginnen und kollegen im
europäischen parlament wurden monatelang
entscheidende informationen vorenthalten
das ist inakzeptabel genau diese art der
mangelnden kommunikation zerstört das so
dringend notwendige vertrauen in der
bevölkerung und schwächt die
demokratischen institutionen
daher darf dies sich so in dieser art
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nicht
wiederholen
wir sehen jeden tag welche dramatischen
folgen die pandemie für uns alle hat und
daher ist es richtig neue europäische
instrumente der zusammenarbeit und
gesundheitsbereich entschieden
voranzubringen
erstens die krisen vorsorgen die
krisenprävention in der eu muss
verbessert werden
dafür ist eine stärkung und ein ausbau
des europäischen zentrums für die
prävention und die kontrolle von
krankheiten icd 10 sowie der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur ema
notwendig zweitens ist muss einen
verbesserten zugang zu gesundheitsdaten
und den austausch von informationen im
europäischen gesundheitsdaten raum geben
so können folgeprobleme gemeinsam
koordiniert gelöst werden damit es keine
lkw schlangen an den grenzen gibt und
damit berufspendler in den grenzregionen
nicht aufgehalten werden
drittens die arzneimittelversorgung in
der eu muss sichergestellt werden
daher brauchen wir ein herstellungs
standorte von wirkstoff und für
kritische arzneimittel in der
europäischen union selbst und viertens
die eu muss eine führen und gestaltende
position bei der stärkung der bhu
einigen sowie eine vorreiterrolle in der
globalen gesundheit besetzen
ja die europäische union muss
widerstandsfähiger und reaktionsfähiger
werden um auf zukünftige
grenzüberschreitende gesundheitsgefahren
zielgerichtet reagieren zu können
dies gilt nämlich nicht nur für viren
sondern auch für anke mit mobile
resistenzen oder bedrohungen chemischen
ursprungs liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dies ist auch eine absolut berechtigte
erwartung der menschen in der eu denn es
geht um ihre gesundheit bei dem wir nie
politisch liefern müssen
mit der neuen eu behörde von
notfallvorsorge und reaktionen und
gesundheitswesen quasi benannt nach der
griechischen geburtsdaten er soll unter
anderem die entwicklung neuer
arzneimittel auf der grundlage des
strategischen früherkennung auch für
kinder und jugendliche vorangebracht
werden
dies begrüße ich sehr ebenso hat sie die
aufgabe die bereitstellung von
medikamenten und medizinischen geräten
zu sichern sowie die
produktionskapazität von impfstoffen zu
überwachen
eu-weit sind erst 54 millionen impfdosen
verabreicht worden
aufgrund des mangels wer nun selbst
exportverbote diskutiert weil
exportkontrollen kontrollmechanismen so
nicht in dem maße genügend wirksam sind
beziehungsweise eingesetzt werden
dies unterstreicht die notwendigkeit
eines gemeinsamen europäischen und
globalen handelns in der pandemie
impfstoffe müssen allen menschen
weltweit zur verfügung gestellt werden
sie dürfen nicht als luxusgut angesehen
werden daher ist die frage berechtigt ob
die produktion und der verkauf von
impfstoffen ausschließlich nur der
privatwirtschaft überlassen werden
sollte denn gerade den kampf gegen die
pandemie gewinnen wir in einer
globalisierten welt nicht national frau
bundeskanzlerin bitte setzen sich daher
im rat mit voller kraft wie ein tanker
dafür ein dass die richtigen
europäischen lehren aus der pandemie
gezogen werden denn
und mit viel schnellbooten bitte auch
denn es ist genau jetzt die zeit für
eine vertiefte eu gesundheits union die
die bürgerinnen und bürger europas
effektiv schützen um neues vertrauen in
die politik schafft sich in st lisa hat
baradar ii aus der spd-fraktion fordert
die kanzlerin auf wie ein tanker sich
dafür einzusetzen dass es in europa
vorangeht auch im hinblick auf
medikamente und medizinisches gerät und
ich weiß nicht ob sie haben verstehen
können was die kanzlerin daraufhin
gesagt hat sie hat nämlich darüber
gesagt zur rednerin besser als ein
panzer und wir schauen auf den
vorletzten redner in dieser debatte
heribert hirte ist in der unionsfraktion
und er ist vorsitzender des
unterausschusses europarecht aber es
gibt einen punkt angesprochen wurde
das ist die digitalisierung das ist ein
gutes zeichen weil das andere lösen
weise auch die rückkehr zur normalität
ist
deshalb möchte ich einige der punkte die
hier beim europäischen rat besprochen
werden und besprochen werden sollten
ansprechen es soll gehen um die daten
ökonomie daten ökonomie ist die frage
wer hat eigentlich das eigentum an den
daten die wir alle jeden tag auch hier
produzieren wir haben gerade auf
europäischer ebene wir haben es gerade
gehört der tanker europa hat die
datenschutz grund verordnung produziert
die durchaus auch kritik ausgelöst hat
sie ist durchaus im ansatz richtig aber
wir sehen dass dieser ansatz vielleicht
einen punkt nicht wirklich löst nämlich
die frage wie können wir mit den
aggregierten daten umgehen und daher
viel über das impfen gesprochen haben
wir haben gehört dass sich israels
schneller gehen warum geht es da schüler
weil dort regierte gesundheitsdaten zur
verfügung standen
wir müssen hier die balance neu
ausrichten wie wir an diese daten ran
kommen dass sie genutzt werden
und dass auf der anderen seite die
persönlichkeitsrechte gewahrt werden ein
ganz wichtiger schritt nach vorne
wir sehen auf der anderen seite dass
viele unternehmen von daten leben mit
staaten leben manche auch daten
missbrauchen und da müssen wir sehen
dass diese unternehmen diesen wert auch
nutzen können da als wirtschaftsgüter in
die bilanz gesetzt werden können auch
dies ein punkt der auf europäischer
ebene adressiert werden muss wenn er
nicht von dort kommt nicht bei uns
realisiert werden kann ein wichtiger
schritt um die realität des lebens der
daten auch zu reflektieren
ein zweiter großer bereich ist die
künstliche intelligenz ohne künstliche
intelligenz läuft nichts mehr
aber wir sehen auf der anderen seite die
menschen machen sich sorgen wenn sie von
automatisierten systemen sozusagen
überwacht werden mit denen kooperieren
müssen deshalb haben wir im
unterausschuss europarecht über die
fragen wer sich hier stellen schon
mehrfach besprochen und eine der
zentralen fragen die sich hier stellt
ist die haftung zu viel haftung führt
dazu dass die intelligenz nicht
entwickelt wird zu wenig haftung führen
dazu dass das vertrauen nicht mehr als
hier die balance zu finden ist einer der
punkte die jetzt auf dem europäischen
rat adressiert werden müssen
und das alles hängt mit dem zusammen was
sie eingangs gesagt habe mit der
digitalen zur realität die wir anstreben
müssen
der tanker so will ich sagen braucht sie
den kopf und der kopf muss bei uns in
europa sein
deshalb kostet das geld dieses ziel zu
erreichen das ist die andere seite der
medaille
und es muss auch nicht jeder punkt jeder
schritt in europa verwirklicht werden
wir müssen schauen welche punkte
möglicherweise auch in kooperation mit
anderen ländern durch auslagerungen
hinzugekauft werden können aber eines
ist ganz wichtig die zeit drängt denn
wie wir hier nicht agieren agiere andere
und die agieren sonst schneller
und damit bin ich sozusagen bei einer
seiten baustelle die auch angesprochen
werden wird auf dem europäischen rat
nämlich bei der kapitalmarkt union ein
thema was durch die fragen der pandemie
ein bisschen in vergessenheit geraten
ist
wir haben hier eine deutsche diskussion
über edis das einlagensicherungssystem
ja und es ist richtig dass wir sagen wir
wollen dieses einlagensicherungssysteme
nur weiterentwickeln die risikoteilung
die da in grenzen möglicherweise mit
verbunden ist die risiken reduzieren
dabei bleiben wir auf aber wir sehen auf
der anderen seite auch dass die risiken
gestiegen sind dass die schulden
bestehen sind durch die pandemie
unvermeidbar geschieden sind gestiegen
sind und deshalb brauchen wir weitere
antworten auch auf europäischer ebene
wie wir mit diesen gestiegenen schulden
umgehen der wichtigste punkt ist wir
brauchen instrumente der eigenkapital
aufbringen
die menschen müssen investieren in die
neuen projekte die sich nach der krise
auch wieder stellen die wieder zur
verfügung steht damit der neue mut auch
aufgegriffen werden kann
wir müssen kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen stärker unter die arme
greifen und wir haben gerade vor wenigen
wochen hier umgesetzt europäische
restrukturierungs richtlinien das war
eine schönwetter richtlinie die für die
restrukturierung großer unternehmen
adressiert vorbehalt vorgesehen war
wir haben gemerkt für die kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen fehlt da
einiges da müssen wir nachbessern wie
wir das in der deutsch-französische
parlamentarischen versammlung auch
gesagt haben
da ist viel zu tun viele möglichkeiten
jenseits des schuldenmachens wie das
manche als die einzige lösung ansehen
und ein letzter punkt die europäische
kommission hat in den letzten tagen ganz
deutlich gesagt gegenüber china wie dort
mit den buchen umgegangen wird das geht
nicht sie hat zum ziel ein ganz
wichtiges außenpolitisches signal und
ich würde mir wünschen wenn vom
europäischen rat das signal ausginge
vielen dank
debattierte war das nochmal aus der
unionsfraktion und auch der letzte
redner kommt aus der unionsfraktion für
die panther erwarten wir am rednerpult
mitglied im ausschuss für die
angelegenheiten der europäischen union
und demzufolge sollten wir auch in
diesem letzten redebeitrag in der
aussprache zur regierungserklärung der
bundeskanzlerin noch ein paar
europapolitische aspekte hören und dann
sind wir mit dieser aussprache auch
durch kollegen und kollegen frau
bundeskanzler zum ende dieser debatte
kann man feststellen ja sie war
insgesamt weniger geprägt gerade im
ersten teil von den notwendigen
vorausschau auf den bevorstehenden eu
gipfel sondern natürlich etwas mehr auch
von einer nachlese der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und ich
glaube wir können heute feststellen das
war auch richtig so denn der unmut über
die ergebnisse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vom montag
war groß im parlament im land viele auch
ich haben das natürlich auch in ihren
wahlkreisen gespürt deshalb war es aber
umso richtiger und das möchte ich zum
schluss dieser debatte auch noch einmal
ausdrücklich anerkennen dass die
bundeskanzlerin ein fehler erkannten
eingestanden und abgestellt hat dass wir
heute darüber so offen debattiert haben
und das verdient unseren respekt zu
bekunden und gelegt bevor wir den blick
aber auch die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zum
abschluss noch einmal werfen möchte ich
auch noch einmal auf den bevorstehenden
eu-gipfel eingehen denn die
regierungserklärung heute dient
natürlich nicht wie es mancher kollege
genutzt hat jetzt einer
generalabrechnung mit der korona politik
sondern sie dient vor allem dem umstand
dass wir unserer verantwortung und
unserer parlamentarischen kontrolle in
eu-angelegenheiten nachkommen können und
dafür ist natürlich entscheidend das
große w
weisende entscheidungen für die
europäische union beim gipfel anstehen
und ich möchte ausdrücklich auch zum
abschluss noch einmal zurückweisen wenn
jetzt aus reihen der ard mit blick auf
das programm next generation eu die rede
von einer schuldenunion ist dann zeigt
das nur wie sie vor parlamentarische
verantwortung kapitulieren denn wir
haben hier im parlament dafür gesorgt
dass genau das nicht eintreten wird
sondern zukunftsfähigkeit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und es geht es
beim eu-gipfel natürlich um die
bewältigung der pandemie lage in europa
und auch um das zurückgewinnen von
verloren gegangenen vertrauen wir haben
und das wurde heute natürlich vielfach
diskutiert natürlich auch kritik übt an
der impfstoff beschaffung auf der eu
ebene aber umso mehr ist jetzt doch die
zeit der verantwortung das auch zu
kompensieren und dafür gibt es chancen
indem wir zum beispiel über den knappen
impfstoff den wir jetzt haben darüber
reden dass der dann auch mit
exportbeschränkungen in der europäischen
union verbleibt oder dass wir die chance
nutzen mit präsident biden darüber zu
reden wie mit den usa eine lösung
gefunden werden kann und auch das ist
eine konkrete erwartung an den eu-gipfel
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und es
wird darum gehen dass wir uns auch auf
den weg machen den diskussionen
natürlich über den digitalen eu passt
denn klar ist für uns eröffnung des
gewerbes öffnung der hotellerie reisen
die wir alle wieder erleben wollen in
zukunft das wird es eben nicht nur und
soll es nicht nur mit regionalen insel
sum geben sondern möglichst union zweit
in einem mehr ebenen system und dafür
brauchen wir gemeinsame lösungen und
einen fairen umgang miteinander in der
eu aber auch in unserem land liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und dieser
schwere umgang das leitet über
abschließend noch einmal zu einigen
überlegungen auch mit blick auf die
debatte der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundeskanzlerin hat sich ja dazu
geäußert und hat was ich schon anerkannt
habe verantwortung übernommen für eine
entscheidung die ihm nicht nur ihre
entscheidung war für eine entscheidung
die ein einstimmiger beschluss war für
eine entscheidung die auch
parteiübergreifend getroffen wurde
armin laschet markus söder andere mehr
haben darauf hingewiesen haben richtig
darauf hingewiesen aber und das ärgert
mich nicht jeder hatte die größe dazu
sondern manche sind im wahlkampfmodus
verhaftet geblieben und herr mützenich
sie bezieht sich ausdrücklich nicht mit
ein aber malu dreyer meinte noch gestern
zu verkünden die kanzlerin sei selbst
schuld und auch manuela schwesig ist
wieder großmeisterin im schwarzen peter
spiel und ich schlage eines geht nicht
immer am verhandlungstisch sitzen und
dann darüber zu reden die eu der bund
sei schuld aber man selbst trägt keine
verantwortung das kann doch nicht
richtig sein liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die pandemie
ist kein alleiniges problem des bundes
sie ist kein alleiniges problem von
cdu/csu und nicht wir nicht andere
parteien sondern das virus ist der
gegner und auch das muss eine klare
aussage dieser debatte heute sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
menschen erwarten jetzt perspektiven sie
erwarten darauf hat ralph brinkhaus
hingewiesen einen funktionierenden staat
sie wollen kreativität und mut und genau
das werden wir hier im parlament
gemeinsam mit der exekutive auch auf den
weg bringen allen verhandlern jetzt beim
eu-gipfel und für die bestimmung für die
abstimmung in der bund länder ebene
alles gute wir haben das vertrauen dass
wir dieser pandemie nicht mit angst
sondern mit lösungen begegnen und auch
das ist ein signal der heutigen debatte
in liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlichen dank philipp am torhaus der
unionsfraktion letzter redner in der
aussprache zur regierungserklärung hat
sich nochmal geäußert zum eu hat auch
zur corona politik der bundesregierung
ganz unabhängig davon einer der mdb
durch deren sagen wir mal grenzwertiges
agieren die debatte über transparenz
regeln fahrt aufgenommen hat das war ja
bei ihnen schon im vergangenen sommer
der fall